you
this year's prize in economic sciences
is about markets where sellers and
buyers have difficulties finding each
other the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences has decided to avoid this very
ascetic spank prize in economic sciences
in memory of Alfred Nobel 2010 jointly
to Professor Peter diamond at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
Cambridge we saw professor Dale
Mortensen at the northwestern university
evanston you saw and professor
Christopher piece our readers as a
London School of Economics and political
sciences in england UK and the academy
citation runs for their analysis and
markets with search frictions
you